de c'est mon choix sur cher et 25 crois
tu veux en venir
on a fait la connaissance de thomas et
loup alors c'est vrai couple absolument
charmant certainement mais c'est un
couple libre qui accepte que chacun
puisse avoir plusieurs relations
en même temps on regarde et on s'en
parle juste après quelle est la
différence entre l'infidélité ce que
vous vivez avec d'autres personnes parce
que je viens avec d'autres personnes
c'est dans le contrat entre très très
gros guillemets qu'on a avec thomas
c'est à dire que les choses sont très
claires entre nous personne ne souffre
de la semaine quelle est la différence
entre l'infidélité est ce que vous vivez
avec d'autres personnes mais ce que je
viens avec d'autres personnes c'est dans
le contrat entre très très gros
guillemets qu'on a avec thomas c'est à
dire que les choses sont très claires
entre nous personne ne souffre de la
situation et surtout on communique
énormément et on ne se cacherait en fait
commence à devenir sérieux avec notre
relation je demande à rencontrer la
personne la peur qu'on peut avoir quand
on voit ça s'accompagne aller avec
quelqu'un d'autre
cette coupe est comme ça très court très
rapide très bien qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce couple marié 68% des
français qui pensent que l'on peut
rester avec une seule et unique personne
toute sa vie est ce que vous croyez
cet amour là cet amour à damien fait non
alors qu'ils viennent se marier super
vous parliez de ces personnes magnum
écouter parce que je dis 68 8% des
français pensent que l'on peut rester
avec hélas la même personne et unique
personne oui toute sa vie à la je dis
oui
cet amour libre là ça vaut pour moi
c'est le modèle traditionnel de la
famille qui fout le camp c'est à dire
qu'avec ces nouveaux jeunes fini le
couple stable où il ya deux personnes
pressées nouveaux jeunes oui à damas que
pour moi ce sont des objets c'est à dire
que pour moi moi pour moi n'y a rien de
plus beau que deux personnes qui
s'aiment et qui s'offrent toutes les
fidélités tout leur amour torrent toute
leur vie donc à partir de ce moment là
pour moi je pense qu'on peut leur
reconnaître mois qu'ils ne sont pas
hypocrite
au moins ils se disent les choses ne
sont pas hypocrite oui en attendant faim
pendant je trouve ça assez punk quand
même comédie mais ils ont surtout 20 ans
elles sont archi me
c'est des ados ils ont juste envie de
vivre des expériences de ne pas être
dans les gamins d'aujourd'hui est bon et
des limites et je comprends très bien
que à cet âge là d'accord on n'est pas
forcément envie de dire à une seule
personne
ce sera toi pour le restant de ma vie
maintenant ce format là franchement il
est incompatible avec une vie de famille
et dès lors on a trouvé le père de ses
enfants celui en qui va devenir le père
de ses enfants
on a également un mois vous auriez
accepté un compagnon qui vous dit je
vais voir ailleurs
alors ce cas j'aurais aimé que mon
compagnon accepte moi que je puis
d'accord mais ça fait partie de
l'expérience de la vie on sait pas trop
on est là c'est on va et ça marche quand
on est adolescent quand on est jeune
d'accord que justement on ne se met pas
de limites qu'on va se mettre plus tard
quand on est dans une vraie vie d'adulte
d'accord